[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis gamin nous ignorer le banc en
troisième année à liberté mais également
aux intérêts privés un rappel
photographe et en charge le compte des
bonnes histoires
j'avais terrain disputa - ivoirien est
en fait la promotion du cmfi accidents
sont liés
il est préparateur logique avait été la
fierté pour nos villes à cela j'ai
embrassé impact en passant par guerre
parce qu'on fait des piqûres et donc nos
distances ce soir c'est distingue par
son petit-fils qui après avoir passé
plusieurs univers avant d'avoir en
guyane et xfr la littérature conseil
c'est cette histoire que je vois pour
processeur est donc mon fils par elle
ainsi fait une petite erreur
c'est la première fois que mon père a
été nommé deux il m'a dit camille anaïs
à patricia nouveau et littérature sinon
il fait baisser le pied est venu
apporter à rigoler mais ce soir on
plaint devant nice partielle des furies
figurez vous paraître et c'est vieux
suffisait celle là ton histoire peut
faire partir dé l'histoire et d'un mieux
mon histoire va faire partir ou telle
histoire
je la prépare et un but voire à dos
après jour on parle de situer dans le
présent notre ami je viens de fêter ce
beau dans l'histoire il faut d abord la
distinction entre l'histoire et le passé
par le passé c'était effacé je ne parle
pas des tendres
je vous parle d'une histoire l'histoire
et de présence et marque de ne pas
cesser le mouvement perpétuel
accouchement qui est présent et
futuriste sauf que d'amener ou pas
doivent elles à s'écrire
il ya des anime actuellement et après
à venu france ô et donc pourrait venir
un moteur bonus par vous pourrez faire
partie de l'histoire et ce charabia puis
je la porte de l'histoire afin d'y part
du constat consacré fait un constat
pièces peuvent également fait le buzz
parce qu'il vise pas des indemnités
l'histoire de mon pays l'histoire peut
donc l'histoire c'est le récit de la vie
de certaines personnes
c'est la mi temps et c'est bizarre je
vais compter l'histoire de l'humanité se
dire que l'histoire et le destin de
cette personne
on vous passera par exemple désolé la
capot on vous parlera pas répondu aux
appels voix là vous a passé neuf tables
qui un jour s'est levé le matin on
dirait qu'il t'a assise à la mauvaise
place mallet que cette fin elle est
assise au bon endroit
cette partie de l'histoire on va là de
pablo picasso un pays légendaire acquis
aucune page de résister mais les temps
avait chargé d'histoire à l'histoire a
décidé de l'italie sont au paradis
genivar une des solvants ni la moitié
des dépenses puisées dans la mise en
scène
l'artère avenant les jeunes filles en
2014 le père avait à peine 17 ans a été
sacrée binôme et de la paix est ce que
les membres se disent pas c'est que ceci
n est pas de réussir des pauvres elle
dénote une ration le met à genoux
alors je lui dis si cette personne veut
marquer l'histoire
s'ils l'ont fait partie de l'histoire
ou parce que le où ledit va partir et
l'histoire nous parce que johnson
matthey ma génération
alors j'ai dit c'est le faire il fallut
pinceaux et froide en fait elle est le
parti du line up entre patelis par où
passent qu'une histoire est bien le
délire et dans mes réflexions j'ai aussi
dit sa personne n'a fait face qu'à
travers en particulier que vous me
battais histoire est ce parce qu'ils
avaient des passions ou d'élus des
compacteurs l'idée d'embrasser vous êtes
juste j'ai supporté des appels reçus
je constate je veux pas que ce qui a
fait que l'histoire allait payer on veut
réussir parce que cette posture et jours
ont décidé de faire du gras seront elles
résister de gandhi investi d'écrire leur
histoire
elle reste pas fait de télé petite envie
d'arrêter des projets et dormir les
accueillir la vie d'intérim existé mais
vivent
j'ai de l'espoir à 21h30 - fait partie
de l'histoire et je veux communiste et
fait partie de l'histoire parce que vous
faites partie de l'histoire
ce n'est pas compliqué sur les imprimés
n'y a pas de ma femme est en nette
hausse mais on n'est pas tous conviés
pour beaucoup le texte fois l'histoire
moi je veux dire que de marquer
l'histoire il faut comprendre l'histoire
presque stable à sony smartphones parce
que lorsqu'il va mourir il veut pas que
l'on insère simplement pas mal dieu que
condensé d'histoire que des la
commande ans après dans dix ans n'en
perd pas j'ai pas que je disparais au
départ nous faut qu'on parle de moi
rumeur partie de l'histoire de ma
famille de mon pays même du beau monde
donc on va se le dise pas fonctionné
ouais l'ispa ma famille je vous la
définit comme
des reports il ne retient que les
reports les barreaux cela se passe dans
l'histoire du foot avec des reports
avoir un temps avoir un ton une partie
crise et le sida cnls et plus ce soir
développé par an et donc ce soir dans la
surface à ce qu'on peut maintenant
découvrir en tant qu'écrivain vous voyez
alors que le soleil est plus cultivé et
hebei sa part que pourrait détenir en
fait je ne savais rien faire je ne
savais pas pensé je ne savais pas
chanter des hommes à jouer au piano n'y
arrive pas à voir ce qu il suffit au
visage de son parti d'erding est clair
de pizzas jeudi a tourné vers ses
nouvelles par les visions c'est parce
que les démêlés avec le minispace
septembre 2009 tu parles pas être ébloui
redira du seigneur dit cette loi passe
déc' la paix revient des trucs sur 40 m
waouh naturellement riche dominique
lafargue gens comme moi cette histoire
arrive face au creusot kevin parent en
fait ces gens qu'on n'a pas dérougi
nouvelle 8,9 à 9,1 ce père j'étais né
avec un stade bien fait et comment fais
tu veux que comptable qui ne l'est pas
et c'est que active rappelle une dame
vivant s'appelle des olives aux parents
merci au parvis frais voire vie qui est
des deux familles pauvres c'est pareil
elle s'est parée à 9 heures et violée à
kazan et la russie n'a aucun avenir
la vessie revenir à la chanson
des fouilles désinstalleur le match
n'avait pas brillé et reconnais pas
l'histoire mais pas votre peine
légendaire artificielle et pas même vers
la rue wilson mjc est permis de le faire
je peux le faire parce qu'elle est
négligée par les marsouins du désert
humain attendez vous à un petit
comptable bien que scientifique
et vous appelez à faire que dire de qui
il ya quelques jours que je ne pouvais
pas faire il y avait expliqué après mais
d'abord il fallait la vinothèque de
tension est vive
le livre c'était l'anarchie gibrat bbc
afrique heures dans le coeur et la
saône-et-loire
j'ai lu ce livre il m'a passionné image
auprès des membres dans la littérature
avec une plaque à visiter plus grands
mathématiciens et physiciens et donc en
tête par beau temps est gratuit et
musicien fait que tom baker voir si elle
veut atteindre ce niveau
toute vérité réussite ip est ténue est
pas possible moi pasqua n'est venu
d'arabie l'histoire des egos avoir
interviewé en rythme annuel
attachante et el masri al yom le cuir en
vertu du matin se lève à 6 navires de
l'aurore elle varie selon la peur est
patent est ma patrie panneaux et
embrassades quelque chose par là il va
te des forêts onf et des politiques qui
vont donner envie de dire une moi je
pouvais rien faire je n'ai pas qu elle
est coincée impossible que tout enfant
je voulais me sellini alors la grande
ourse aussi des rapports révolution dans
les rues dans la rioja sur mon histoire
franchement sadique et cri du coeur il a
été comme un joker il n'est pas leader
google
lui l'a dit qu'il voulait et là moi je
veux écrire il y aura peu de soufre du
monde et m a fait du mal est fait
pascale terrât petit frère ou des pieds
sont vêtus du kouign aman a fait là car
on savait que tout était à deauville à
midi esquive d'évadés alonso et lui et
le maintenir hélas les premiers romans
taches noires de frittage d'affaires 9
mois sur le banc super dans ce registre
et s'il ya vraiment des gp tell avant
est parvenu à la littérature
il n'aurait pas pu il est aussi dit
d'abord c'est vrai dire on sait écrire a
dit de figure mais il faut qu'ils
fassent différents vois je me suis fait
que la fée la coi devant l'appât du gain
ce n'est pas seulement les moyens de
france et tu n'es pas seulement les
décisions
j'ai pas ce jour c'est pas des stars au
delà fixe d'abord la voiture ça aussi le
sport les héros mais j'y allais était
une nouveauté dans la fiction de
l'incident avant tiennent à le rester
pour votre héros bien tu te lèves sans
être torride et poète route
il avait l'histoire est arrivé en base
est assez rapide téléphonie par ip
transfert n'avait en effet pu monnier
payer mon histoire l'histoire spécial
mon histoire est uni et ce qu'il faut
faire parce que je l'avais voilà b
heureusement pour moi je me suis bien
entraîné
l'onu ce départ brûlé nice par ses
déboires américains pour servir d'eux et
malheureusement j'ai récupéré mon
document et avait demandé facebook
pardon évidemment ils n'ont pas abouti
il va me motiver pour connaître les
suppliques petit jeu conçu et pensé
qu'avec les pilleurs si vous vous
rappelez
ça faisait mal et ça m'a fait vraiment
bizarre
il fallait connaître celui là je
découvre qu ou pas de quoi se payer 700
mille six cent mille invités pas mal de
mes parents vivent en paix mise au point
d'obliger premier mur j'ai failli
baisser les bras parce que sur facebook
est reconnue a annoncé à l'édition de
ses apprentis degen et là il va m'aider
pour un crime ce qui fait que tu n'écris
pas pour plaire aux gens qui n'écoutent
pas couper un débat reste hypothétique m
est rien et enfin vous êtes vous donner
c'est que contamine pas ce que veut la
vivre c'est ce n'est pas les moyens
d'une rivière passion alors ne ratez pop
et du parti quoi revoir vos envies et à
ce que j'ai fait j'ai pris de bons
billets y avait de poésie avec des deux
petites nouvelles
tout ça pour ça ont été maintenus ne
passe pas par brême a l'expérience d'une
fusée en 2010 parce que je ne pouvais
pas répondre que c'était quand même et
la 3ème année
voilà ce qui va se passer vous lorsque
vous décidez ratures à deux relégations
administratives
venance que deux points des écrivains à
buenos aires dont la
participez au point de nouvelles
centrales prennent pas de reprise
technique
le débat est donc au départ qui avait
mérité
il m'avait pris en faute et je veux
gagner sur le fait ça bien fini en point
de presse en conclusion cet honneur mais
il n'arrive à rennes où la firme asie
par après que les pompiers eurent
prononcé alors trente minutes su
prévenir des risques par les cas cités
alex un masque sur le visage parce que
l'éternité
ils vont booster l'autre - et gallèse ya
base est la vie ce n'est pas vrai parce
qu'elle avait peur alors on a passé
beaucoup et le support après y'a des
étudiants musulmans comme on s y arrête
à phau 6 1 de bourganeuf parce que
depuis cinq ans rapportent les yeux il
avait choisi le public et donc j'ai fait
ça et un animateur du raffinage à la
prendre à des colons afin de vous re
c'est exact de file de plus vers midi et
j'ai rencontré beaucoup ne seront
visibles que d'autres verront où l'on
écrit sortir le journal
enfin je ne pouvais pas imaginer tout le
match il aura bientôt sur coup ça les a
libérés il a global dérisoire de ma vie
mais ça veut dire est évidemment vous
arriver d'avoir fait maintenant ce que
vous disent pas tenir passe pas mais je
voulais view veut jouer les gones
espèrent la première part il ya la
photographie
ses trois agresseurs et accrochez vous
il ya de cela six mois c'est ma faute et
de vaincre a poursuivi
mais c'est vrai et là vous êtes
producteur pour la mairie et ceux
importés
la société est passée par là et là je
vais fort que la semaine prochaine qui
est vrai qu'après en comparaison des 17
tirs ouverts dont la révélation est dans
sa croisade lancée sur place à des mini
guide comme ça m'a plu et qui menace
était vrai et en fait juste assez pour
la place de dauphin au cours de cette
réforme et je m'occupe pas des dix ans
et du coup on m'a posé on m'a payé et on
me dit qu'il ya de pire dans l'édition
du nom ce n'est pas parce que le combat
chez les mieux conservées étude a su que
ça puisse pas voilà par les soucis qui
paraîtra il paraîtra bientôt a accueilli
de côte d'ivoire édition fouilles au
nord du pays bas a laissé un goût du
mois de mai qui s'est pas prévoir que mr
libéral au pérou cette vidéo est venue
enseigner c'est que certains personnages
histoire le thème saint pons par partie
des espoirs hommes connaissent par apa
l'histoire je ne peux pas un passé une
histoire si tu n'as pas ton histoire et
moi ça faisait 10 par an passé neuf
années consécutives
j'ai décidé qu'il fallait plus grands
diffuseurs de notre marché est là
maintenant
peut-être que être entre m j'espère pour
ma famille passionnée finement sa
disparition qu'est ce qui vous pousse
ainsi vous soyez vous seriez déposa et
vous arrêtez de manger de dormir d'aller
à l'église de l'informer de notre
premier conseil que vous prônez vous les
choses en main qui vous fait apprenez
l'histoire et ça ça me réussit son
[Musique]
histoire de faire l'art et l'histoire ne
rase pas rêver mais on l'a dit il ya bcp
normalisé de windson if i ever lose
passé la meilleure en effet qu'avec des
sandales avec le bnd madeira généreux ne
sait qu'on part avant je me vois pas
aller pas à pas je vous répète pas et
malgré la bonne ou mauvaise et après ils
pas daily beast et là je me dis en fait
voilà ce qu'a produit ce sont me
réveiller est ce qu'il peut faire
si je vous dis merci
[Applaudissements]